The last MRI two weeks ago showed a much increase in cancer in the spine.
What is your best recommendation for this?
So remember, if you have a breast cancer in a metastasized to your spine, it's still
breast cancer, it's not bone cancer, spine cancer, something like that.
So the treatment as far as what you're doing specifically to try to kill the cancer, whether
you're doing, you know, you name it, there's 100 different nutraceutical type treatments
or you're doing chemotherapy or you're doing immunotherapy is really not going to change
just because it metastasized, regardless of whether it metastasized the spine or something
else.
Now there may be something that you would do to help support the loss of bone if it
metastasized to bone.
So if cancer metastasized to bone, it's going to be what's called osteolytic, I mean it's
going to cause bony destruction, so it's going to eat away the bone and destroy the bone.
Well that happens if weakens the bone and bone serves as a source of nutrients, a source
of minerals to the body, your bones are very living, they're not just dead structures that
just support you physically, but there's calcium minerals going in and out of bone all the
time you have osteolytic and osteoclastic activity in bone all the time, but when you have
this excessive osteolytic lesion that's going on with bony metastasized, you're losing
bone and you know you're losing those minerals and one of the main minerals of bone that
gives it structure in the inner part of the bone called the endostium is calcium.
So if it is in a weight bearing bone, which the spine is, so the spine, certain bones are
weight-bearing bones and certain bones aren't weight-bearing bones, your fingers aren't
weight-bearing bones, they're not holding you up physically, your spine is, so if you lose
too much mass, too much of the density of the bone in let's say the vertebral body which
is the part of the spine that is weight-bearing, you could have what's called a pathological
fracture or collapse of the vertebral body and you know that it's going to pinch the
nerves and could pressure on the cord and could give you all sorts of different problems.
So you do want to try to you know add nutrients to increase the strength of the spine.
So taking a good source of minerals like like reacted minerals are clear multibands and
the best source of calcium is the osteo-k product called osteo-k, it's the correct form
of MK4, most of the K's, the vitamin K's out there are going to be MK7, you need MK4
and extremely high dose to get calcium into the bone and osteo-k is the only no supplement
I know that has that, so osteo-k would be something that I'd recommend it plus taking
other minerals as well.
Second part of the question, it was also ER positive years ago so they assume that it still
is estrogen receptor positive and should I get a change in my rife programs and should
I try to keep the ball near my spine after time, breast cancer was the main diagnosis, liver
lungs have had some issues too.
So yeah if the closer you could keep it to the site the better and do you need to change
the rife program, though as I stated before it's still breast cancer, it's not bone cancer,
so the programming should stay the same.